on this episode of stack chat we welcome
Matt Brown infrastructure engineer is
Spotify here how kubernetes played a key
role in making the migration of spotify
backend micro services as seamless as
possible for the 200 plus teams involved
[Music]
thanks for trying to be met so why did
you choose kubernetes over what I'm sure
were many other alternatives for you so
we've been using containers for a long
time since about 2013 cynstalker was
very new we had built our own container
orchestration system around 2013 before
there really was other choices out there
we named it Helios and we open source it
coincidentally the day before kubernetes
was announced so we didn't really know
at the time that there was something I
was coming that we use and so we knew
for I think for a long time we didn't
want to continue to be in the business
of building our own
orchestration platform kubernetes is a
wonderful open source project a huge
amount of contributors great velocity
and so we knew eventually we wanted to
move over to it just to get a lot more
features and impact from the community
and we think in the end the
orchestration platform that will have
this thing the offering we can make to
our own engineering team is gonna be so
much better if we can be a part of this
big open source movement instead of
having a team of four or five engineers
building our own thing internally we
thought it would take or at least I
thought initially we'd have to do a lot
of selling kind of talking nudging
people along pushing people along at
some point but we found that most teams
are pretty motivated to to adopt
kubernetes so how did you approach doing
this transition from your custom-made
orchestration to gke
over time a big principle we had for
trying to figure out how are we going to
move over was trying to we what really
wanted to make the migration for each
engineering team at Spotify as easy as
possible we feared if we had to teach
every team times 200 or so teams how do
I use kubernetes or if it was a
completely different system from what
they used today different metric systems
different ways to do logging etc or if
the two systems couldn't talk to each
other then migration project
ending because Spotify back-end is
organized into hundreds of thousands of
micro services from different teams
talking to each other and so one thing
we really were afraid of and wanted to
avoid was in order from my team to move
my service to kubernetes I need to
organize with the other teams calling my
service and we often move it at the same
time that would have led to a ton of
dependencies and would have taken many
many years to move it one service over a
lot a lot a thousand we had built a
system on top of Helios that we called
tugboat and it really just give us a
simpler interface and API and we
realized what we already have almost
every service at Spotify
talking to this API and basically they
can just say they can tell Ted but I
have a new version of my service please
go deploy it out to the world and it
gives a much simpler interface helios
was a little bit low level and so we
realized well if we just add kubernetes
as another option to the system we
already have everything integrated with
it if we wanted to find a new
next-generation deployment platform for
example we'd have to do all the work of
integrating it with it all over again so
we just basically added kubernetes as
another option to both had a new way the
pros and cons of kubernetes with your
own management versus manage gke
deployment so over the years as we were
trying to think when is a good time to
start seriously adopting kubernetes and
we did want to wait for a while because
helios helped us make great strides and
it seemed like kubernetes was still kind
of growing so figuring a lot of things
out just like any project as we were
doing that and kind of waiting for when
is the right time we were moving our
whole back-end to Google cloud anyway
getting rid of our own data centers so
there wasn't really much of an arguments
if you had to say like we want to build
our own clusters learn how to do all of
the networking do all the stuff
ourselves the hard way one of our main
motivations for adopting Google Cloud in
general was just to take advantage of
many managed services and so our teams
can kind of focus on upper layers and
spend less time on like the lower level
things so then with all these services
how do you make sure that as they're
shifting they can still collect metrics
and understand their context within that
Spotify micro services ecosystem we did
a lot of work as an
your team to make sure that the things
that if your team is building a
container the things that you would see
in the environment and our own system in
Helios would look mostly the same in
kubernetes and that's things like
service discovery would be handled for
you that was one of the features of
Helios metrics were provided by just a
process running on an own port on the
same machine as your container so you
could just send metrics to that we had
similar things for secrets and logging
so we did a lot of work to make sure
that all that looked the same in
kubernetes so that you as an application
or what we call a feature team really
didn't have to rewrite your code at all
you can just take your container which
is already packaged up and move it to
the new if you enjoyed this episode
check out the stack chat playlist for
more videos
[Music]
you